FCC commissioner says government should
ban Tick-Tock okay the Council on
Foreign investment in the U.S should
take action on Tick Tock Brandon Carr
one of five Commissioners at the Federal
Trade Commission with more than 200
million downloads in the U.S alone the
popular app has become in a form of
critical information infrastructure
making the apps ownership by the Chinese
patent company a target of grow National
Security concern China's based Engineers
working at Tick Tock addressed
non-public U.S user information
including phone numbers and birthdays
and BuzzFeed reported in June bite dance
which is the based in China instructed
employees to push probation messaging to
U.S users of a news app BuzzFeed
reported in July bike dance planned to
use tick tock collect information about
U.S certain U.S users according to
Forbes report published last month let
me say this part here I have zero trust
in this company I have zero trust in
their management team I have zero trust
I created an account on Tick Tock and
I'm going to tell you openly here the
only reason I did is to give the things
I believe in on the people on Tick Tock
that are not being heard so I was
talking talking at you know China I was
talking capitals anything that they
don't support I was talking about it
and then gradually uh you saw what
messages they didn't like we did one
video on China prior to that I did the
numbers the other day with Kai the prior
100 videos I think some 10 of them got a
million views five of them got five
million views but should have got a
hundred thousand views prior hundred the
moment I clicked put a video about China
after that 400 videos on Tick Tock only
one of them got over a hundred thousand
views zero over fifty thousand views 400
videos of those 400 on Instagram they
all performed okay but only one got over
a hundred thousand views it's the
Antonio Brown clip Tick Tock is a
gamified company uh I'm we're still
posting stuff because we want them to be
held accountable on what they're doing
but this company is one president away
from being banned in America the current
president doesn't have the audacity to
do it because he's he needs those 1918
new tick tockers that are making videos
saying good things about him if he bans
Tick Tock game over but the next
president's going to have the audacity
Tick Tock is one president away from
being banned in America it can happen in
2024-22 Pat Tyler made a great point on
my podcast because we're talking about
all these challenges the Kia challenge
where you just steal a key and kids are
crashing and dying and you know the tide
pod Challenge and you were saying it
they're dumbing the NyQuil challenge the
NyQuil the knife challenge they're
making our youth not only the attention
span this short but dude they're
literally making our kids poison
themselves to kill themselves and it's
like well um someone's Revenge a leader
eventual is going to have the audacity
to shut him down I can't wait for that
day I gotta wrap up quick thought just
on this and what's what's the name of
the Chinese TV station in America where
you can watch all the Chinese stuff
[ __ ] it doesn't exist is my point I was
just like okay media is a thing that
countries use to control uh narratives
in in populations social media is even
more
precise and the algorithms that social
media can do can Target you you know all
day who to Target what to say there's no
reason that Tick Tock should go so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]